Welcome to lesson two. In this lesson, we'll learn
about the advantages of using R to perform data analyses.
We'll install RStudio. And we'll learn the basic data
types and commands of R. Before we get started, I
want to share with you how one data scientist used R
to improve the health outcomes for the citizens of Chicago,
Illinois. Data scientist Corey Nissen used the R programming language
to analyze tweets from people in the city of Chicago.
Corey analyzed tweets in real time by searching for the words food poisoning
in each of them. I want you to read more about his analysis and
his work by clicking on the link in the instructor notes. Try to
find the answers to these next three questions as you read through the article.